when Rupert Murdoch's lawyer arrived at
court it was with a poker face no hint
from veteran attorney Dan Webb that
behind the scenes settlement talks were
running to the wire
the world's media were poised for a
five-week trial that promised so much
testimony from the biggest star anchors
that America's most powerful News
Network testimony from Murdoch himself
but inside away from the cameras the
court sketches reflected the drama we
were watching in the room frantic phone
calls from lawyer to client as Fox did
all it could to stop this going to trial
then with the trial's opening statements
nearly three hours late an announcement
from the judge the parties have resolved
their case
and with that the fox lawyers were off
what's the settlement worth Mr Webb
no answer instead a statement
we acknowledge the Court's rulings
finding certain claims about Dominion to
be false this settlement reflects Fox's
continued commitment to the highest
journalistic standards we are hopeful
that our decision to resolve this
dispute with Dominion amicably instead
of the acrimony of a divisive trial
allows the country to move forward from
these issues their payment to make all
this go away
787 and a half million dollars on the
court steps the boss of the voting
machine company that brought the case
fox has admitted to telling lies about
Dominion in throughout this process we
have sought accountability and believe
the evidence brought to light through
this case underscores the consequences
of spreading lies so do you expect an
apology from Rupert Murdoch all right
guys good day for Dominion good day for
democracy
and so the U.S news crews who thought
they would be here for weeks are packing
up but this was always about so much
more than them reporting on their own
industry it was about a false claim that
the election was stolen a claim that so
many people in this country still
believe
we don't know the small print of the
settlement precisely what deal was done
but the reflections of the day will be
on one man
how's he feeling Rupert Murdoch I guess
he's feeling pretty glum at this point